hi Hannah congratulations how you
feeling I am so excited this is amazing
it's surreal but I'm ready to get going
I mean I saw you in this like princess
dress moment we have gone from Alabama
Hannah to Alabama Cinderella how does
that feel Bachelorette I mean the dress
is so beautiful and it's super fun today
has been just all things beautiful and
princess but just wait oh we're shedding
that oh we are and we're coming in
fierce oh yeah I look getting fun
looking for some fierce love or sure uh
yeah I loved that when I loved when you
said that so we've got a little bit of
the princess maybe a little southern
belle moment maybe I'll be clean I saw
the pageant Quinn is the pageant queen
gonna be a storyline for you I don't
know I'm just gonna be Hannah I think
but I do think a lot of my life I've
struggled with showing what I think
other versions of what I think people
are going to like about me and pageant
queen was one of those but we're
shedding that and I'm just gonna be
Hannah like just experience I'm asked
the Bachelorette and that's what I want
my man to know is Hannah's true self
I really think through my experience
with Colton you've got to see me come
into my own but I think as the
Bachelorette you're gonna see me
continue to grow and share that with the
men this season and just be really
honest and vulnerable and share my tree
you notice pretty cool Hannah this is
the 15th season of The Bachelorette and
you are the first one as far as we can
tell to not be from the Final Four which
I think says something about you how
does that feel to be chosen like that
well yeah I didn't expect it I knew that
I had laid it all out there I've been
and I'd really grown and my experience
was amazing
and I really believed in the process and
even though it wasn't my love story I do
believe that it can happen for people
and it has obviously in the past so I
wanted it so bad and I felt like it
could be me but yeah it's never happened
before
think I'm just real and I hope that's
why it was me and I want to continue
that and I promise that with each man
that walks through that door that
they're gonna see me but I'm going to
expect that in return mmm I like that a
little bit of that southern fierceness
oh yeah mm-hmm
girl I ain't gonna play when did you
find out that it was you and what was
that moment like I was just sitting at
home on my couch
and I get a call from Oh Chris Harrison
and I wouldn't even let myself believe
it at first because because I didn't
finish in the final four it was I think
it's a little bit unique that it is me
and even when they call me I'm like why
are they letting Chris Harrison cover
the news but it's not me this is this is
ridiculous but no yeah he called me it
was and I was in front of the mansion it
was like hey you're on you guys
Bachelorette
and um my parents we're at home and my
bride there and it was the sweetest
thing ever I was just crying and
cheering and just so excited and then
Chris paid me a visit Tuscaloosa we had
some fun down down south and Here I am
so really every I've had every single
emotion but it's an emotional journey
and I've tested them all out before
we're good yeah and uh I'm just really
grateful day well you know it and I like
you saying that I've talked to you about
this we really saw you grow this season
which I loved I mean in the beginning
you know it was some people what how
would you describe yourself in the
beginning like I set up the train wreck
not miss I think that covers it
okay so you've gone from train wreck and
hot mess to Bachelorette like if you
look at that girl in the first kind of
half of colton season did you ever think
she'd be bad
right here right now no no I mean I
think what was happening is I was I was
real but I was trying to figure out how
to handle my emotions and wasn't doing
it in the most eloquent way but I think
we all struggle sometimes but it was
just capturing for everyone to see we
struggle and come into my own but in
those few moments absolutely not
I mean well you've come in it was bad
you've kind of gone from I mean some
people were in the beginning like it's
your season villain and now America
loves you yeah I know I'm aware but it's
not weird no it is but I think I think
it helps me for my season coming up
because I think I can be compassionate
and relatable to every man that's gonna
walk through that door because I'm like
I was every I was everything that walks
it there because I did grow I'm spillin
I was the emotional train wreck I was
the the friend that kind of got I mean I
just feel like I can relate yeah to a
lot of different places I didn't just
have a big Coast through at all
I wasn't just coasting in the back
corner you guys for sure station on
through yeah yeah and so honestly I
think my journey not being the easiest
it's gonna help me be understanding and
compassionate for the men that come
through the door well we saw you also
you know this dress you're wearing today
has like kind of a train to it a little
bit of wedding dress vibes I did feel
like that a little bit today like I feel
it feels really good but I've I've had
some wedding sheets in the past like
just snow and some modeling so I'm like
I've done this before but like oh maybe
I won't have a thick fiancee at this
time and a fake wedding dress made it's
do you believe soon I was gonna say how
much do you want that because you've
talked about this fierce love and I know
you talked about not wanting to kind of
fall into some of the stereotypes of the
south maybe but on colton season no
proposal no engagement yeah will you
have an
at the end of this that is that is what
I hope for yeah I think of course like
my my hope is to I've been to this have
somebody that knows me and knows all of
me and I know them and I feel very
confident about them getting down on me
and asking for the rest of their life
with me and I can say yes so that is
what I'm hopeful for but to get there I
want unconditional wholehearted love and
so that's the main goal and then
engagement I'm hopeful for it so
absolutely all right well we saw some of
your your train wreck moments your
breakdowns how many breakdowns and tears
will we get with you as Bachelorette I
have all fingers I don't know eyes yeah
I mean I I just promise to be real and
honest and vulnerable the whole time and
whatever emotions come with that come
with that three deal-breakers somebody
who is good look they had to be good
like a nose three must have everything
has to be honest trustworthy and just in
it for the long haul any deal breakers
he'd be like nope not the guy for me if
he did this they were a lying sack of
poo and what's your physical type when
he attracted to it sounds so bad but it
looks like somebody like that hasn't
like that five o'clock shadow what sort
of haven't bathes in a few days that
smells like they have that's perfect
yeah
you